Rich Eisen the NFL Network host and
hosted the Rich Eisen show on DirecTV
audience Network channel 239 that
follows this one also on BR live.com
good morning rich how are you
DP how are you I'm doing okay I'm
curious that people if I ask them right
in the middle of that quarterback sneak
is this a good idea for Patrick mahomes
before the injury what do you think how
do you think people would have responded
to that question course it did come on I
mean how many times have we seen a
quarterback sneak and a quarterback does
not have his patellar tendon moved by
the pile
I mean Brady's done it a million times
he's the king of it he's done it so he
did it for touchdowns twice last week at
age 42 it's just a freak accident a
total freak accident and maybe it can
also be born out of out of the fact that
the Chiefs running game is essentially
prior to last night before McCoy ripped
a few off totally non-existent you know
I mean they they have no running game of
which to speak to lean on to perhaps
keep their defense off the field to
perhaps keep the pass rush from pinning
their ears back and going at mahomes who
was hobbling around like Freddie Sanford
for much of the season so far and I
think you pour it all in there and you
got people thinking that was a poor
choice of a play call if you're Andy
Reid do you stay with Matt Moore well I
mean have we heard anything yet no okay
so yeah you do the crazy thing is he
hasn't had a single snap all year but
that makes sense because you have
Patrick mahomes and so yeah that's what
you do but if you find out if he's out
for the full season you know I I don't I
don't know what plan they would have I
see a lot of talk about Eli Manning and
again you had a 24 year old who can run
like a deer as your reigning MVP behind
that offensive line that again would
love to hit people as opposed to be hit
with a with a run game that really
doesn't exist
I could I could only imagine if that
scenario got
mahomes limping around what would happen
with Eli Manning back there and I I just
I just don't see that the only option I
would say and I'm going to say it on my
show I'll say it here too is is if if
mahomes is out for the full year if that
does in fact happen then they got up
they should kick the tires on Kaepernick
they should absolutely see what's going
on there
I think Kaepernick and the Reid offense
the way that they're coordinating it
would be dynamic if he's able and
willing and everybody can get on the
same page and again Andy Reid is as a
coach who once gave a second chance to a
guy who stole that 11 worth and maybe he
could do that convincing but that's a
long way potentially away and by all
accounts it looks like we're less than a
month away from maybe mahomes returning
the question of the week and it feels
like I've stumped everybody when I ask
it second best team in the AFC you know
if my home is hurt is what you're saying
this is even before that and I didn't
watch the city or the second best team
yeah I would have said the Chiefs really
you know yeah because my homes is have
you ever seen anybody like him I mean
ever I mean we've seen guys who can run
around we've seen guys with cannon arms
you've seen guys who can do both
well Rodgers I've seen Rodgers do this
right correct that you you could make
Rodgers you could put him in that mix
but uh even some of the throws that
mahomes makes we haven't even seen
Rodgers attempt I mean I don't know how
many times you've seen Rodgers go no
look or or left-handed and I know that
that's circus stuff but it's worked so
mahomes is just such a difference maker
he can he can turn a third and 20 from
instead of a three and out to a to an
80-yard touchdown quote unquote drive so
that alone I think would put him put
them in that category but the way that
the Shaun Watson is playing yeah III
however see the Texan is having a very
difficult spot in Indianapolis Colts
coming off of a bye week this week
which would throw the AFC South wide
open talking to Rich Eisen NFL Network
and host of the Rich Eisen show
available on DirecTV the audience
network and B are live coming up at the
top of the hour the Jalen Ramsey
straight I wasn't I didn't quite
understand it because I didn't feel like
that addressed the biggest issue that
they have and you're also bringing in a
corner who do you have to shut down in
that division so it's not like you're
bringing him in to go I got to shut down
that receiver when we face them twice
tell me how Jalen Ramsey improves this
Rams team that they get back to being a
Superbowl caliber team oh gosh he
removes half the field from from the
view of your quarterback that you're
trying to put on the turf and if he even
gives an errand Donald a split extra
second to get to the quarterback lookout
and and it might not just be to win the
division first of all Tyler Lockett is
somebody that I know that the Rams have
blanketed and even even Russell Wilson
has found that six square inch loophole
to put the football and and they need to
start winning some football games it's
not just the division they got to start
winning some games and which is why you
know I'm sure they're very happy to see
you know I know that there's holistic
medicine here and people eat well and
you know Los Angeles has a nice
lifestyle but man that back got better
really fast for Jalen Ramsey and just in
time to face Julio Jones this weekend so
it it's not just the division it's gonna
it's gonna be this week right away but
the offense though is the issue well I
mean the offenses the running game I had
less to eat on my show yesterday and
that now completes pretty much everybody
I haven't had the owner on but I've had
the coach on the general manager on and
and and a you know mjd and other people
who have followed this team and
everybody swears that that Girly's knee
is not an issue it's just the amount of
miles that have been on his knee they
want to remove
the foot from the gas pedal and and
allow him I guess have weeks ten through
eight seventeen or for them eighteen
nineteen and twenty have him with his
high volume as opposed to weeks one
through six or seven and and that's the
issue in the run game if it's not
working and the offensive line isn't
firing the play actions not working and
in golf is under duress so I understand
that Ramsey doesn't run it and it won't
make it more efficient on offense but if
the offense keeps getting back on the
field a little bit more and keeping the
defense fresher because Jalen Ramsey is
getting off the field and unless he
basically said hey we looked at it in
2020 are you have to figure there their
draft choice will be in the bottom half
of the draft if not bottom third or
quarter and they're not going to get
Jalen Ramsey there mm-hm and they you
know they've locked up the quarterback
and the running back and a wide receiver
and you know Donald it's not like that
they need these first-round picks to
start finding tentpoles for their team
so when I said if I said to you rich you
can have jaylen Ramsey for two
first-round picks or Trent Williams from
the Redskins for two first-round picks
and you're the Rams well I still go
Jalen Ramsay he's generationally
talented dad I mean he is he's he's
tremendous I can't believe Jacksonville
coughed him up unless you know obviously
it was so bad I think you even heard it
in Doug morones voice this week I know
he's just like I'm done with that so
somebody else answered a question on
Jalen oh but you got to spend a lot of
money on him to come and I know and they
know that already they know that already
I asked that of Les as well and he said
that you know they didn't talk dollars
and cents with his agent before pulling
the trigger on the deal but they know
they know I mean it certainly two first
round picks being coughed up you know
that they're gonna have to pay him and
they'll figure it out they have I mean
that this defense right now there's
there's ten games left in the season and
they still can be one of the best teams
if not in their division in in the
conference and making the move I thought
was aggressive and smart when it all
comes down to
right the ongoing julian edelman
hall-of-fame debate that we somehow
created and i mean how many times do you
beat this drum well we we didn't bring
it but we didn't bring it up this time
around it's surfaced again and then you
know we thought well we should probably
bring it up again
okay can you can julian edelman be the
modern-day lynn swann where regular
season not not elite postseason
unbelievable I think he can be why not I
mean when when Brady goes into the Hall
five you know years after whenever he
decides to stop playing we'll be talking
about what Brady did Gronk and probably
Brady to Edelman some people you know
might bring up Brady to moss Welker you
know I mean his first his first Super
Bowl that I covered when he beat
Carolina and Houston he was flinging it
to 15 different people and then Deion
Branch you know caught all those
footballs against the Eagles but Edelman
is Edelman is his clutch as they come I
mean you need the first down you need
you need a big moment in the postseason
so yeah the answer to that is yes I
think is the whole thing I would feel it
I think one more time I feel it you know
you think like this year would seal it
and it's a may it's just amazing I mean
it is really amazing how the Patriots
just keep chugging along and they might
be better now than they have been at any
point since 2007 I mean they really
might be I know they don't have
glunk and they don't have you know
anybody on defense that you can
literally point to and say that's your
Pro Bowler but they are just so deep and
so good and brady is so unbelievable
they are the best team in the AFC and
I'd be stunned if they were not in in
South Florida at the end of the year I
mean who's right now who's going to go
in there
with with everybody playing the way that
they are and I know there's a long way
to go who's gonna go into Gillette and
win an AFC Championship game against him
like who would it be - Shaun Watson
maybe on a big day and if the Chiefs can
pull it all together I mean who's gonna
go do that yeah I you know Harbaugh
seems to have the number of the Patriots
but you know I'm asking Lamar Jackson to
go in there against Belichick and a lot
yes it's a lot I mean I think he was a
little more seasoned than I I would say
the Ravens can do it and the Texans
could do it because one thing you can do
or if you can do get into shootout with
New England you can beat them but yeah
you know that's where Kansas that's why
they wanted to keep Antonio Brown
because they know at some point they
have to have some offense this is a team
that won the Super Bowl with defense
last year you know I think that they
they realize they're gonna have some own
that's like craft on you know when I
woke up in London last week and and I
read about the bloodbath because the
game when Thursday Night Football or any
night game in London is played while
you're sleeping and I woke up and I saw
craps went on the pregame show and
basically just just told Gronk you know
don't don't lose our number or look for
the six one seven area code you know and
on your phone it's the record doesn't
matter they know they know what might
beat them in situational games against
certain teams and certain downs and
distances and which weapons they need to
overcome that and that's why they wanted
a Antonio Brown that's why all the word
when all the craziness was going down
with the Robert Klem coppice that did
lead to finally the parting of ways that
you heard that some members of the
coaching staff didn't want to lose him
and that's why you're hearing about
Gronk now it doesn't matter if they're
eight and oh they know what would hurt
them come December in January they're
that good at planning so I'm still and
it'll be interesting it looks like
they're taking the hands-off approach
now saying let browns be Gronk let them
go let them go hang out at Fox let them
go you know top rope with the WWE but I
still believe when it comes down
to it in November and December
somebody's going to kick that tire who's
on the show we have omar epps the actor
and then the directors and producers of
the lego movie would be most notable for
Phil Lord and Chris Miller and from the
Denver Post Mark Kistler will be joining
us on if you read what he wrote yes what
he wrote yes yes you know I was going to
text that to fritz but you know the game
will shoot definitely didn't need to use
it last night
hey not after that punch that fake punt
I mean I almost burned my putters or
people to t-shirt thank you rich have a
great weekend you too but that's a Rich
Eisen NFL Network host for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]